débâcle désastre ce lundi matin le
verdict de la presse allemande est sans
appel l'accès des où le parti de la
chancelière angela merkel vient de
recevoir une volée de bois vert
électorale en rhénanie palatinat
les chrétiens démocrates se sont
inclinés face aux sociaux démocrates du
spd avec 27 7% des voix soit 4 points de
moins qu'en 2016 idem en bade wurtemberg
où les conservateurs arrivent loin
derrière les verts avec une baisse de
plus de 3 points en 5 ans soit les pires
scores du centre droit allemand
enregistrés dans selander du sud du pays
mesdames et messieurs pour le dire en
toute franchise ce n'est pas une bonne
soirée électorale pour l'accès des où
nous aurions souhaité de différent et
meilleur résultat dans ces élections
régionales du bade wurtenberg et de la
rhénanie palatinat un revers électoral
qui s'explique entre autres par les
récents scandales touchant les membres
de la cd ou et de la ds ou sa jumelle
bavaroise de députés chrétiens
démocrates sont soupçonnés de corruption
pour avoir reçu des commissions de
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
pour des achats publics de masques à une
période où l'allemagne peine est à sont
procurés et un autre élu conservateur a
dû récemment renoncer à son mandat pour
des liens financiers avec l'azerbaïdjan
à cause du comportement vraiment
indécent et l'absence de gènes de
certains députés
justement maintenant dans la phase
finale de la campagne électorale nos
militants ont pris un vent contraire
cela n'a pas seulement été désagréable
cela a aussi pesé sur la campagne
électorale ce qui explique ta cela ne va
qu'à place des affaires auxquelles
s'ajoutent les critiques concernant la
gestion de la pandémie et la campagne de
vaccination sans oublier des déboires
politiques plus anciens le 5 février
2020 pour barrer la route aux
socialistes en tête du scrutin dans le
land de thuringe lattes cd ou s'était
allié avec la droite extrême pour
l'élection du ministre président de la
région
du jamais vu depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale
le tollé provoqué a eu de lourdes
conséquences dont une crise interne au
parti de la chancelière et la défection
de la présidente fédérale de la cd ou à
negredo comme karine bauer c'est là
qu'ils angela merkel avait passé le
relais à un an plus tôt renonçait le 10
février 2020 à ses fonctions tout comme
à la chancellerie chrono pour toutes ces
raisons et dans l'intention de renforcer
l'accès des où j'ai donc aujourd'hui
après de longues délibérations informé
le présidium et le comité exécutif
fédéral de la décision suivante je ne me
porterai pas candidate au poste de
chancelière on n'a pas tous la canéda
toit aux dames
ces soubresauts politiques avait
entraîné quelques semaines plus tard la
défaite de l'accès des ou aux élections
de hambourg divisant un peu plus les
chrétiens-démocrates des chrétiens
démocrates qui ne savent d'ailleurs
toujours pas qui envoyait à la conquête
de la chancellerie en septembre prochain
le modéré armin laschet est élu à la
tête de la cd ou en janvier dernier
peine à convaincre
face à lui le patron de l'axé s ou
marcus soeder chaque jour un peu plus
apprécié des allemands
scandale financier défaites électorales
locales et difficulté avoir un
successeur dans gala merkel émerger 2021
pourrait bien sonner la fin de la cd ou
au pouvoir après 16 ans de mandat pour
la chancelière